bonjour comment dumas moulant en forme
farid et christophe n'ont pas oublié
michel nicolas président fondateur de
l'association espoir dévouement depuis
30 ans ils l'ont aidé à aménager ce
chalet de la liberté cet espace
d'accueil destiné aux femmes et aux
hommes battus aux anciens détenus aux
humains en détresse
farid il a même séjourné dans un moment
difficile de son existence
c'est pas moi qui vous mettra la main et
ça non tu es chez toi pouvoir pour toi
il a organisé ça autrement on reçoit
donc des gens qui viennent avec leurs
blessures
avec leur souffrance pour redémarrer une
autre vie ça leur permet de trouver un
rom d'accueil où il reste le temps qu'il
est nécessaire pour redémarrer dans la
vie ça m'arrivait bout quoi bon bah du
pardon changement des impôts rats pour
pouvoir partir et bien là qu'on trouve
quelque chose
entendant et puis fait d'un saint sava
soirée c'est un changement pour une
personne qui est que j'avais vu que nos
vaches à lait franchement c'est aussi
une expérience en matière vous aidant
chalet mais vous êtes au quotidien avec
eux c'est à dire on parle où on se voit
on boit le thé ensemble ou on va
discuter on va manger ensemble
il va avoir des idées puis on va essayer
d idées qui pourraient mais s'est
améliorée ce qui fait farid a pu
rebondir et s'ancrer dans le monde du
travail
en séjournant plusieurs mois dans ce
chalet grâce à son savoir faire
il a permis d'apporter une petite touche
de confort supplémentaire
christophe lui aussi à aider à
l'aménagement des extérieurs ça peut
aider oui c'est vraiment sur certaines
personnes qui vont qui vont reprendre la
relève derrière le chic pour le check up
oui c'est important de participer
d'avoir mis un peu l'homme à l'édifice
que ce moteur d'énergie au service des
autres michel nicolas est allé le puiser
aux sources de sa propre souffrance dans
graine de potence il raconte son
parcours d'enfant abandonné tout en
détresse engagé sur le chemin de la
résilience
il a mis 50 ans a retrouvé ses racines
ça sert à quelque chose
c'est je suis un homme épanoui
aujourd'hui
même à 4 fois 20 ans j'ai encore envie
de vivre avec mon passé qui décide où la
vente des livres permet d'aider
l'association avec l'espoir de voir un
jour ce type de chalais s'implanter dans
de nombreuses communes en france